بالحديث عن التحاليل دراسه كانت اجرت
دكتور اختبار للغه العيون وكانت المراه
الاكثر تفوقا من الرجال على كل المعنى
مجموعه من الصور لاعين تعبر عن مشاعر
مختلفه سنستعرضها ونحاول قراءتها معك
دكتور استمع لتحليلك نشوف اول صوره هاي
اندهاش شو رايك نادين انا بس قبل ما اعطي
رايي بدي اخبر المشاهدين انه وصلنا لمرحله
انا وسهام صرنا نفهم بعض من لغه العيون
طبعا
هلا هي مبينه
مبينه انتاج بس اكيد الصوره تخفي وراءها
شيء ثاني يعني مستحيل تكون هذا البارز
للوجه نعم
اييه ممكن يكون فيها سعاده ممكن يكون انا
شخص اكون موجود في المطار
وانبهرتوا عندي اندهاش لاني شفت حبيبتي او
شفنا الانسان اللي انا مستنيه بقى لي فتره
ممكن يكون في اندهاش لانه موقف حدث
الاندهاش ما له علاقه علشان يكون واقعيين
الانتهاش ممكن يكون
الغضب لو في عنا لغه لها علاقه بالغضب
الغضب واضح هيكون الغضب من شيء مش هيسعدني
شوف الصوره اللي بعدها
هلا انا بما انه هي حاطه ايدها على راسها
فبين حدا نتامل تفكير بس مش ما مش من نظر
للعيون للتفاصيل كامله للوجه ولغه الجسد
انا بفكر في اشي
سيء شويه مش شيء كثير حلو لما بنطلع
بالعين لفوق نفس المنظر هذا لو اخذناه
وطلعنا لفوق بيروح على حاجه اسمها للابداع
دائما انت بتكون عندك فكره حلوه انت قاعده
بتفكري في المقطع او قاعدين هان بتلاقي
عينك لتحت عمره ما بيكون احنا بنفكر في
الشيء جات لي فكره حلوه كثير ليه
حتى اللي عندهم اطفال
هاي انا التبني الي بتبناه انه دايما لما
بنتطلع بانسان واحنا الفرج قوى ناطر
مباشره في لغه العيون فكانو هون على نظره
ثاقبه ومباشر مباشره
عشان اعطي له احساس اني انا معك ممكن تكمل
فهي هذه اللغه اللي احنا بنقول حتى في
الاجتماعات حتى في المقابلات حاول تكون
دائما الكنتج تبعك العين زي ما انا الان
بوزعها ما بينكم انتم الاثنين لازم تكون
مباشره فهذه هنا اللغه عين واضحه وصريحه
للشخص الامانه
اوكي
ما بعرف اذا في كمان صوره اخيره
[موسيقى]
رايحه الطرف العين على الطرف اليسار
ان انا بروح على حاجه اسمها منطقه
تقول انا بقدر اكشف اللي قدامي اذا بيكذب
او لا ده من لما بسال شخص له علاقه بالكذب
او المنطقه هذه لما بلاقي عينه بتروح
ناحيه الشمال بيروح على حاجه اسمها
الحقيقه او المنطقه اول ما بيروح العين
تبعتي ناحيه اليمين بروح على الكريات
والابداع على ما بالذات المراه بتكشف
جوزها انه كان المستشفى ممكن تروح
السرحانه ممكن انا بس انا هلا هاخذها
كتحليلي انا كان له جسد او لغه العيون
في المستشفى كنت قاعده مع مع اكس هتلاقيني
بتطلع ناحيه اليمين
كذا وكذا
يعني كانوا هذه مجموعه هيك سريعه من الصور
طيب وتقييمك لتقييمنا
انتم كمان
هذه نوع من انواع الفراسه ممكن الناس يكون
عندهم الفراشه هذه ممكن اكاديميا له علاقه
بانه يكتشف لغه العيون ولكن انتم عندكم
حاجتين مستر تختلف عن باقي الاخرين لانه
مجال العمل تبعكم بيكشف لكم انتم
بتتقابلوا تقريبا ويكلي لا يقل عن 10
اشخاص بتشوفوهم فسرتوا تكشفوا لغه الجسد
بناء على الخبرات اللي كسبتوها زائد انه
انتم نساء حنرجع ثاني الاولى عندهم قوه
على الاسكان زي الاسكان الطبيعي انتم
بالضبط زي الاسكان اللي هو له علاقه
بالكمبيوتر الرجل لسه الاسكان الانولوج
القديم اللي يمكن بالهاند بياخذ وقت
الابيض واسود بياخذ معنا وقت لا طبعا كان
انه من البدايه كنت كل الصور اللي انتم
حلتوها كانت حقيقيه